[Music]
oh look who's there mr president
oh
hello mr president glad to see you glad
to hear you how are you there
i'm really i'm doing it i hope you okay
yeah
uh your mission is to
destroy as many russian troops as you
can
and the question is will you continue to
receive the help you need
and i certainly hope so it's very
important for the united states to
continue in the league of providing you
the the
the support you need you've got good it
seems to me you've got good
communications with the administration
you know your secretary of defense and
people like that are continually
informing our military of what's needed
and our military is very supportive of
what you're doing president you didn't
want to take russia
into nato did you
no i wanted him on the fringe of nato i
wanted ukraine into nato
no i mean i thought for
i thought for a while
russia would be more cooperative and
then putin changed dramatically he's a
rambunctious
uh
boy at heart
uh yeah i i agree i mean he uh
yeah we had a problem with him in
georgia
putin later trapped
and he fell into it and uh
uh
and he kind of panicked
during that period of time you should
have asked me whether or not he should
have been inside your government i would
have given you advice but
uh
yeah i hadn't talked to shaka sveely
since 2008
[Music]
yesterday i met with our heroes heroes
of ukraine
they uh they were fighting on the
information front and then they were
mobilizated into uh recruited into uh
ukrainian army
they are pilots
like you
uh they dreamed of talking to you
and
yeah if if you don't mind i will put
them on the line
and they will talk to you many good
things if you don't really mind
and you
oh yeah
hello mr president
how are we doing
we're fighting for
our independence
well i'm very proud of you
we are also pilots like you
there you go there you go yeah
thank you even